[Music]
you're gonna introduce me robert it's my
girl delirious hi what are you guys
gonna do
load up
is it gonna be hard to sell this stuff
no not at all
this is the minimum wage
[Music]
it's taking a chance out here
you got a pocket full of money you want
to taste is your mother doing drugs
every day
these take all the problems off
my mother father got divorced when we
were young put me in the foster home
so i would have stayed there with those
rich folks i wouldn't be here right now
program to find out the results of my
hiv tests
my father works 80 dollars a week penis
you know what your son does to make
money yup i don't like the idea
what did i do to get locked up healing
doing drugs
free again
got any jobs i need a job
a lot of people went through a lot of
trouble to help me now why am i going to
mess that up
in and out of jail in and out of jail if
you go back on drugs can't live
how long you've been working the streets
i'm awake
if you love us so much why are you not
doing so good for us
you never try
[Music]
i don't know what i'm gonna do with my
life
stay strong okay
just don't give up
don't give up i know you can do it mom
[Music]
you